To understand a religion, don't look at
the followers. Study and analyze the
scriptures, the sources of the religion,
the Quran and the authentic hadith.
Suppose you have a latest Mercedes
S600
2025 model. That's launch. You know they
launch 2 3 months before the year ends.
So 2025 model comes out in November
December 2024. You want to check how
good the car is. A person who doesn't
know how to drive the car, he sits
behind the steering wheel and he bangs
the car. Who will you blame? The car or
the driver? The driver, not the car. If
you want to know how good the car is,
you like to know how many cc is it? What
is the cc? 5,000 cc, 6,000 cc. What is
the pickup? What are the luxury things
that is present in the car? What is the
horsepower of the car? What is the top
speed of the car? And if you really want
to check how good the car is, put behind
the steering wheel who's an expert
driver. If you want to judge Islam, read
the Quran and the Sai hadith. If you
really want
an exemplary Muslim, the best exemplary
Muslim in the world is the last and
final messenger, Prophet Muhammad, peace
be upon him. Analyze his life. Look at
him. He's a walking Quran. He's a living
Quran.
look at his LIFE AND YOU CANNOT TAKE OUT
a single mistake.
So today what you say that Muslims are
terrorists, Muslims are fundamentalist,
Muslims are cheating. Yes, there are
black sheeps in a community. The media
picks them up and portray as though
they're exemplary. Yes, we Muslims
should improve. I'm not supporting the
black sheeps in a community. They
actually not Muslim. They're namesake
Muslims. They're not practicing Muslim.
But as a whole, we Muslims are the
biggest community of tea toters, of
modesty, of sobriety, of charity, of
humanness, of loving, of mercy. There is
no religion that can throw a candle TO
US, CAN COME CLOSE to us. So Islam is
the best way of life. That is the reason
Allah says in the Quran in surah Imran
chapter 3 verse number 19
Islam the only religion accepted in the
sight of Allah is Islam. Allah says in
surah Imran 3 VERSE NUMBER 85 IF ANYONE
DESIRES ANY OTHER RELIGION BESIDES ISLAM
IT WILL NEVER be accepted of him and he
will be amongst the a losers.
So this was the reply to the 20th most
common question. These were the 20 most
common misconceptions question that a
non-Muslim can ask. There are some
important questions. For example, can
you prove the existence of Allah? I have
given the talk on this topic. Does God
exist? About two and a half hours talk
and question answer session five hours.
Shaman may ask can you prove the Quran
to be the word of God? I have given a
talk on is the Quran God's word and the
one in Malaysia was long two and a half
hours talk and three and a half hours
question answer session about six hours.
There was one question earlier which was
20th now it has gone out of the list.
The non-Muslims say why does the Muslims
why do the Muslims abuse us by calling
us kafir? Short answer therefore I'm
giving when a Muslim calls a NON-MUSLIM
A KAFIR IT'S not an abuse. Kafir comes
from the Arabic word k which means to
reject which means to conceal.
If you translate kafir INTO ENGLISH IT
IS NON-MUSLIM. Anyone who rejects Islam
or conceals Islam is called as a
non-Muslim. SO NON-MUSLIM I'LL CALL
NON-MUSLIM. SO SOME CHRISTIAN call me
non-Christian I will feel happy because
I don't want to be a Christian. If a
non-Hindu calls Dr. Zakin as a non-Hon
Hindu. I'll be very happy.
I don't I don't want to be a non-Hindu.
So why should the non-Muslims
feel bad when they're called non-Muslim?
If you really don't want to feel bad,
only thing you have to say is believing
in one God and believe Prophet Muhammad
is a messenger of God. You say the
shada, you'll be a Muslim. We'll stop
calling you Kafir. We'll start calling
you Muslim.
This was in brief regarding the most
common questions, the most common
misconceptions. I request my brothers
and sisters
learn the answers. It's available on the
net in the book form. It's available on
the video. I know yesterday was 2 hours
15 minutes. Today is 2 hours 15 minutes
and I tried to give full answers. So the
full answers is 4 and a half hours not
counting question answer session. So the
replies in detail to the 20 most common
questions or 20 most common
misconceptions is about 4 and a half
hours. Of course you can give more
details to it. Time is limited and I
would like to end the talk with the
quotation of the glorious Quran of surah
Isra chapter number 17 verse number 81
where Allah says
when truth is in falsehood falsehood
perishes for falsehood is by its nature
bound to perish.
Lalam.